we have chemicals that are in use and we
have emissions that are really super
polluters they're the ones that are very
high in terms of their carbon emissions
and that's methane
is one of them it is highly global
warming hfcs are another which is
hydrofluorocarbons which use in air
conditioning and and freezing and and
refrigeration so the us has moved
forward with hydrofluorocarbon
regulation where by 2030 we will lower
it by 85 percent the amount of
hydrofluorocarbons emitted in the united
states that's a significant reduction
because we can there are opportunities
in the system that that just need to be
nudged along so that we can move that by
regulation but we're going to come with
a global methane pledge that that nearly
if not 100 companies the countries are
signing on because methane is again
a super global warming chemical and so
there are opportunities to actually in
the oil and gas sector in the u.s to
start reducing those emissions we're
going to do it by regulation and by
working with the private sector we're
talking about our agriculture again we
have opportunities for reductions there
we're talking about pipelines and
regulating them more effectively and the
whole value of this is it buys time it
takes a chunk of the greenhouse gas
emissions out of the system so that we
can actually have a little bit longer to
ensure that that 1.5 degrees still keeps
within reach so it's hugely important
it's outsized benefits for small amounts
of action and frankly in the us when we
look at the costs and benefits it saves
a ton of money because if you're working
in the oil and gas sector all you're
doing is emitting your product if it's
natural gas and the same with with
agriculture we can do better so that's
what we're pledging to do and we're
trying to get every country in the world
to engage similarly because we think
that will get us a little bit of time to
achieve the reductions that science
demands